Homelessness has been rising in
America's West Coast cities for
more than a decade.
Entire blocks of Los Angeles,
San Francisco and Portland
are occupied by tent encampments
plagued by violence, drug
overdoses and disease.
But the problem is concentrated in a
handful of cities.
While nationwide, the homeless
population has been shrinking for
a decade.
To figure out why some places are
so much more successful than others,
we took a trip to Texas, where
the homeless population declined
almost 30% over the last
decade as it grew by more than 40%
in California.
Today, the Lone Star State counts
90 homeless people per 100,000
residents versus California,
where the problem is almost five
times as bad.
Not only does Texas have vastly
different politics and policies
from the West Coast, but it's also
home to three large cities with
three very different approaches to
homelessness.
Austin, San Antonio, and
Houston.
From a privately run village of tiny
homes just outside Austin, to
a nonprofit serving San Antonio's
homeless with an intensive, no
excuses, treatment and skills
training program to a single
centralized provider in Houston
that streamlined its approach
quickly housing thousands of the
city's homeless residents.
What we found in Texas was
innovation.
But the federal government doesn't
fund innovation.
For decades, it's committed to a
one-size-fits-all approach
known as Housing First.
States like California have followed
suit, leaving many charities with a
choice to either fall in line
or turn down millions in
federal funding and state grants.
The result?
More people living and dying
on the streets as governors and big
city mayors promise that the much
awaited free permanent housing
is just around the corner.
Our first stop was the city of
Austin, where progressive activism
exists in the shadow of a
conservative statehouse.
It's a boom and bust town, a magnet
for business and tech innovation,
which has learned some of Silicon
Valley's top performers.
When the ultra-rich moved in,
housing prices started to resemble
San Francisco's and the homeless
population has climbed.
Policy wise, Austin has a lot
in common with West Coast cities,
which helps explain the huge
encampments here.
But Austin has an advantage that San
Francisco and Los Angeles don't.
When you walk over the city line,
you're in a more typical Texas
municipality, where light touch
regulation allows innovative
approaches to thrive.
The outskirts of Austin are home to
Community First Village, a 51-acre
community of tiny homes.
The project doesn't rely on federal
money and therefore isn't bound by
rules imposed by Washington.
Alan Graham, who founded Community
First Village, attributes
homelessness to the lack of a
supportive network of friends,
family and neighbors, and seeks to
rebuild that network by giving
formerly homeless people the
opportunity to live in a community
again.
You're the best for.
The single greatest cause of
homelessness is a profound,
catastrophic loss of family.
The homes are intentionally designed
with large front porches within a
walkable community to encourage
socialization among neighbors.
To live here, residents have to
respect the law and follow rules
like keeping pets leashed, junk
off their driveways and drug use out
of the common areas, but behind
closed doors, that's their business.
What we always wanted is for people
to live the way that people want to
live here in the United States of
America. We have an extraordinary
number of freedoms.
We don't want people coming into our
homes seeing what we do in the
privacy of our own homes, what you
do there is your biz.
And so we tried to create that same
environment.
But there are three fundamental
rules to live here.
Rule number one, above
all rules. Period.
End of story.
You must pay rent.
The monthly costs for one of these
houses is between 240
and $440, depending
on the size and amenities which
residents typically pay out of their
monthly Social Security or
disability benefits.
Prior to COVID, we had a 99%
rent collection bill.
On time?
I mean, you
know, close. Close enough.
And it turns out that
people that have skin in the game
are bought into the game far more
than people that don't have skin in
the game.
The residents we spoke with agreed.
One thing that I've learned
since I've been out here
is unconditional love, which I've
never had, except from my
grandmother who's dead for over 50
years.
Oh, it's still conditional.
Oh. Sometimes with certain people,
but not with you.
I can tell you this now, honestly,
this the most incredible place in
the world. People and I listen, I
sit down, talk to people.
They just want someone to talk to.
There are a lot of really broken
people here. If you had no one to
turn to,
if you're, you know, financially
broke,
bankrupt, if you have no family.
What can you do at the end of the
street?
And he taught me that.
And that's why we're here every day.
Because when people realize we're
all good people, they're all good
people here.
We love you all.